[Applause]
i'm in ottawa canada's capital city
where these protests are in their 17th
day
lloyd how how long will you stay here
as long as we have to
it started out as a loosely organized
convoy of truckers protesting vaccine
requirements for cross-border travel the
government needs to
quit mandating stuff the government is
overreaching it's mushroom to
include people with all manner of
grievances from masks to
[Music]
vaccines father did
to get our freedom back
and i think we are here for peace love
and freedom to general anti-government
sentiment that's very strong here the
vitriol towards the canadian prime
minister justin trudeau the people these
blockades are hurting
our everyday families is it something
that's dividing people yes 100
um
my neighbors on either side of me
basically told me they hate me and hope
i die alone
um because you want them because it's my
fault because i'm not vaccinated
i think what these protests have shown
the numbers are relatively small in the
context of other coronavirus uh protests
worldwide seven thousand people compared
to tens of thousand people
other cities around the world but what
they've managed to do is cause
enormous disruption not just to ottawa
these streets totally taken over but
also to vital border crossings between
the usa and canada
ambassador bridge for example is the the
major land link between the us and
canada that was shot for five days uh
lori's not able to go over to make vital
deliveries uh to car factories that's
what they've managed to do and that's
why this has inspired copycat protests
in australia in new zealand
and france
because they've shown and the canadian
authorities have discovered that they're
very difficult to move on
[Music]